many people have lots of great ideas and
the challenge there are two problems
with a great idea one is that you're
probably the wrong person implemented
and the other is that you're not done
you have that great idea and so how can
you learn to be better at coming up with
ideas and what can you do with your
great ideas you don't know what to do
with one example I like the idea of
colored salt that way you can do a
better job seeing how much salt you put
on your food but if I did that brought
to market in the end I think I would be
just test marketing for Morton and so
rather than go and start a business
which I think wouldn't ultimately
succeed but I still think it's a great
idea let me put it out there and see
what the world will do with it see if
I'm right Oh for I'm not the most
popular idea on the website is brake
lights that shine brighter when you slam
on the brakes so I think it's a great
idea but then other people have
contributed comments to help appreciate
how you can do even better so not only
have a light shine brighter but have a
change from green to red put a brake
light on the front of the car because if
you're approaching intersection you want
to know is that car slowing down or not
have a rear-facing horn so that way if
the person hits the horn the car behind
you also knows that there's a challenge
not just the one in front of you and
then my favorite is having the brake
light also go on the moment the person
takes the foot off the gas because their
foots heading to the break but basically
you can know before it gets the brake
that's where they're going because they
take the foot off the gas really quickly
and bio if you make a mistake and put
the brake light on by ms extra times it
doesn't really matter and so you might
get that brake light going on a tenth of
a second quicker and that could prevent
an accident so somebody starts off with
a really good idea brake lights that
shine brighter when you slam on the
brakes and then by the time it's gone
through this community it's really been
improved some people are going to be
much better critiquing and proving ideas
other people are proposing them and this
allows those type of
we'll to find each other often we we
sort of beat up put down they sort of
the iconoclasts the creative types who
are coming up always with better
solutions you know it's not broke I'm
breaking and I'm doing it better and
this is a place where why not yet they
can find each other and discover they
not alone that their ideas really aren't
crazy your idea better be ten times
better than what's out there not ten
percent better because you're going to
have worse problems in terms of capital
you're going to have you're going to
have trouble hiring great people when
you're starting out because nobody's
ever heard of you your cost structure is
going to work your distribution system
is going to be terrible so all of those
things that conspire against you and it
therefore if your product or your
service isn't so much better that than
what's out there that people can become
passionate about what you do no point in
making and spending all that effort I'd
say one you can be a great person who
understands grammar and that doesn't
mean you going to write a fabulous novel
so games here is a tool and I'd say
absent the tool you're probably going to
be in trouble some people are perfectly
natural at it whether it be Rupert
Murdoch is probably the leading example
it can help you be a much more
sophisticated negotiator parent
strategist but if you don't have the the
foresight if you don't have the
information to put in there all right
it's not going to get it's not going to
give you the answer that's not what it's
designed to do and so I think can help
you get up to speed much more quickly
and it may help you reach a conclusion
so I would say that the people I've met
who have been the most successful
executives are applying this in in
everything that they do
to me so it allows me to get to speed
very quickly in lots of different
situations it's pretty much the case now
that every student has gotten in an MBA
for the last 10 years has had some
exposure to this in some ways Mike
Porter really brought game theory into
business strategy and so you don't have
to say oh this is game theory every time
you're using it and therefore I guess
I'd say everyone who we teach the
black-scholes option formula isn't able
then go out and make Warren Buffett like
the investments either you are the
strategies it is a opportunity anyone
from a high school student to an
executive to appreciate how game theory
applies to your business your life to
understand whether it be motivations and
sentence how what you do send signals to
others how to read signals that they're
sending to you how to structure a game
not just play the game and we do it
through lots of examples there may be
one equation the book but not much more
and so through this story telling and
anecdotes you'll really have an
introduction to what it was that John
Nash did and what people talk about when
they're doing game theory so you'll be
able to understand it and and use it if
you really want to be kind share it with
others too so you don't just an unfair
advantage
Oh